it's pretty crazy how many celebrities
have real-life doppelgangers for
starters Mila Kunis and Sarah Hyland
have an ongoing agreement that they can
pretend to be one another Will Ferrell
had a little rivalry drum session with
Chad Smith from Red Hot Chili Peppers
and Lucy Hale nearly broke a woman's
heart in the airport because she wasn't
Selena Gomez
Mila Kunis and Sarah Hyland get mistaken
for each other so much that they decided
to play along with the Trope when they
first met at a party in December of 2010
Mila told Sarah that whenever she would
get mistaken for her in public she would
love to play along because it would make
her feel young so Sarah asked her if she
could do the same I was such a massive
fan and everyone always told me that I
looked like her so from then on out they
had this ongoing joke that they would
always play along whenever it happened
apparently Samara weaving has been
mistaken for Margot Robbie an insane
amount of times even to the point where
fans would come up and ask her for
pictures because of it she's tried
denying the fact that she's Margot but
because of her Australian accent people
just think she's lying and is trying to
be rude to them yikes so now at this
point she just stands there and poses
for the picture okay but for real
Natalie Portman and Keira Knightley do
look frighteningly similar I've been
chased through an airport as Natalie
Portman I mean Natalie Portman a lot
regardless of whatever hairstyle they're
rocking at the time the resemblance is
uncanny in fact they actually look so
similar that Keira Knightley played
Natalie Portman's double in Star Wars
Episode 1 The Phantom Menace Kira
actually had no idea that was the role
she was playing because everything was
super secretive at the time they just
kind of kept on shoving me forward and
I'd be dressed in exactly the same thing
that she was dressed in in some of the
wider shots they would end up using Kira
instead of Natalie because Natalie
wanted to head home early as she should
Zoe Deschanel would get confused with
Katy Perry so often that it started to
get on her nerves a little bit
misunderstanding I'm Zoe eventually
after meeting Katy Perry the confusion
started to grow on her everyone kept
coming up to her and telling her how
much she looked like Katie then after
seeing her in person she realized Katie
is absolutely gorgeous and was very much
okay with it oh my queen
it's like looking in a mirror Will
Ferrell has a strikingly similar look to
the drummer of The Red Hot Chili Peppers
obviously because they both have a great
sense of humor they took their little
rivalry on Jimmy Fallon in 2014.
literally dressed exactly alike and had
a little drum off we were tricking you
that whole time this is Chad Smith and
I'm Will Ferrell excellent you got to be
kidding me yeah Jessica Chastain and
Bryce Dallas Howard have known for a
while that they look alike because their
fans always confuse them do people come
up to you on the street and say hey I
love you Jessica chastaining you have to
yeah all the time when they did the Help
together that was the first time they
addressed the issue and actually got in
front of a mirror together to do a
little comparison of course they don't
mind the confusion and similar to Mila
Kunis and Sarah Hyland they often didn't
go along with it for fun and I had this
moment of do I tell them that they're
wrong and it's not me or do I just
pretend I'm Bryce we all know Halsey is
a huge Millie Bobby Brown fan noticeably
from their Halloween costume back in
2016 where they were dressed up as 11
from stranger things Halsey also told
Jimmy Fallon that she thinks Millie
Bobby Brown would be the perfect person
to play her in a biopic Millie would be
great but I don't really think I'm
famous enough to cast Millie Halsey and
her fans alike all agree that the
resemblance is pretty insane it's kind
of uncanny how much we look like it's
like oh no we actually just look like
sister it's not hard to understand why
people would mix up Jesse Eisenberg and
Michael Sarah back in 2014 Jesse and
Michael bumped into each other on the
street and Jesse confessed that he gets
mixed up for Michael Sarah at least once
a day on a side note Michael Sarah says
he gets mixed up as people all the time
including John Peter from Napoleon
Dynamite Coco Jones has been getting
confused for Jennifer Hudson dating back
as early as 2012. she actually guest
starred on the Jennifer Hudson show and
Jennifer asked the crowd if the two
looked alike obviously the crowd
confirmed our suspicions and gave them a
huge
and then they shared how often they get
mistaken for one another I get that so
often that honestly at this point I just
play into it it seems to be a theme with
all of these celebrities Coco also plays
along with it Jennifer Hudson says when
it happens to her she doesn't tell them
who she really is but she says she's not
Coco but thanks them for the compliment
when Lucy Hill was younger she would
always get mistaken for Selena Gomez and
would oftentimes play along I mean truly
who wouldn't want to get mistaken for
Selena Gomez it was Peak Wizards a
Waverly Place time when all of this was
happening one time in an airport a woman
asked Lucy for a photo and she was happy
to pose with her mostly because she
thought the woman knew she was Lucy Hale
not Selena Gomez she didn't realize the
woman thought she was Selena Gomez until
she started listing off projects that
she admired she played along because she
didn't want to disappoint her is Lucy
Hale related to Selena Gomez I am we're
actually twins Victoria Justice is a big
fan of Nina Dobrev and is happy to be
recognized as her look-alike back in
2015 she introduced Nina as her
real-life doppelganger when she
presented her with a Teen Choice Award
obviously the internet was in a choke
hold later that year when the two took a
picture together at a polo event Rupert
Grint confessed to James Corden that
whenever he gets mistaken for Ed Sheeran
he has no problem playing along again
are we surprised it's kind of 50 50 now
it's like someone stops me it could go
either way I could be Ed or I could be
me yeah to indulge in the Trope Ed
Sheeran cast Rupert Grint in his music
video Lego house where they wore
matching outfits people are recognizing
you as Ed Sheeran which is
Hillary Swank says she often gets
mistaken for Jennifer Garner and asked
for autographs all the time she's even
had people get super mad at her for
denying an autograph thinking she's
being rude when really she's just not
Jennifer Garner it's actually pretty
alarming how rude some of these fans
were even to the point of swearing at
her when she denies a picture I'll be
like oh God I'm such a big fan I love
you an alias and I'm like oh
now at this point do not give Jennifer
Garner a bad name is being rude to her
fans she'll just pose for the picture
when she told Jennifer Garner about that
experience she was shocked to find out
that the same thing happens to her these
two iconic women were always getting
mistaken for one another Susan Sarandon
gave a great speech in 2016 at the
glamor women of the Year Awards I want
to just uh clarify a few things while
I'm up here Sigourney has left but
seriously we are not the same person
apparently they've both signed
autographs for one another and
hilariously taking credit for each
other's work
are we surprised people who pretend to
be other people for a living have any
issues playing along with an identity
mix-up the fact that Lucy Hale didn't
want to break someone's heart in the
airport by not being Selena Gomez or
that Will Ferrell had to have a drum off
with Chad Smith to continue their Trope
or Victoria Justice calling Nina Dobrev
her real-life doppelganger at the Teen
Choice Awards proves just how similar
these celebrities look to one another
which pair do you think should have been
on this list